doing we find the distance from a point
to a line and there's more than one way
to do this okay but this is a little bit
of a shortcut using this formula you're
trying to find the shortest distance
from this point to this line okay so
you're trying to find that perpendicular
distance that's going to be the shortest
distance and what we do when we're using
this formula here is we first have to
write the equation of the line in this
form where you get everything on one
side and you set it equal to zero then
the coefficients in front of your X term
your Y term and the constant those are
going to be the values that you're going
to use in your formula that's going to
be your a B and C and then x1 y1 okay
that's going to be the coordinates of
the point that you're interested in
finding the distance from that point to
the line okay so what you do you can see
you multiply a times x1 plus B times y1
plus C you take the absolute value of
that for the numerator divided by the
square root of a squared plus B squared
so it's a big formula okay but it saves
a lot of time when you're finding that
distance so let's look at an example and
you'll understand what how it works so
in this example we're going to find the
distance from the point two one which is
right here to the line y equals two x
plus one so the first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to rewrite this equation
okay so I'm going to do that by getting
everything on one side of the equation
so that's negative 2x plus y minus one
equals zero and then our point here is
to one that's going to be x1 y1 and in
our formula a is going to be negative
two B is going to be positive one and C
is going to be negative one sorry with
me so far okay so all we have to do now
is substitute into our formula and what
we have is a which is negative two times
X 1 which is positive two plus B which
is one okay right here times y one which
is also one plus C which is negative one
and we're going to take the absolute
value of that all divided by the square
root of a squared plus B squared so
that's going to be negative two squared
plus one squared so if we simplify that
down that's going to give us the
distance so we've got negative four plus
one which is negative three plus a
negative one which is negative four we
take the absolute value which
for all divided by the square root of 4
plus 1 which is 5 so it's the square
root of 5 you can rationalize that by
multiplying by square root of 5 over
square root of 5 which equals 4 square
root of 5 over 5 so that gives you the
exact distance from this point to that
line so I hope you understand how this
works a little bit better in this video
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out some of my other videos about
math and I'll talk to you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon